ça pendant les ting halles de narbonne
vouloir piquer les yeux j'avais les yeux
ses amis des jeux ses ennemis bon c'est
une interview dernier coup j'adore
j'adore c'est absolument pas ce qui
m'attend marne sud dernier coup je vous
demandais par exemple dans les coups de
tête facile non c'est pas facile dernier
coup de tête
qu'est ce que j'ai fait à une fringue
une voiture une main mais qu un mec
n'ont ils pas nul hein dans saisine
énorme et peut prendre le temps pour
recevoir à l'évidence qu'on n'aurait pas
fait tout ce qu'on entend par là que je
vais acheter je sais pas moi toi que tu
as mangé un truc que quelque chose
bah j'ai vu un très bon whisky ou une
épilation social en prend
d'interrogation en je dis ce que je
retrouve des coûts
et c'était 3 heures du mat et je
trouvais qu'il était absolument vers mes
cheveux et donc je m entends dire et tu
avais vus non truc à lui c'est à dire
que de temps en temps vous prenez j'ai
pas une cuite mais vous oubliez pas mal
et elle vous explique le lendemain matin
je suis comme neuf
oui vous êtes bien la seule personne que
je connais quai 9 après une cuite mois
le camp est en marche on attend donc
quand vous venez de répondre à la
première question ces derniers coups de
tête vous êtes coupé les cheveux
donc on peut passer tranquillement la
deuxième dernier coup de coeur nous est
un cadeau olivier non non à modeler à
mon avis dans le dernier coup de foudre
olivier
c'est moi contre huawei dernier coup de
fil
dernier coup de fil cet état hollande
veut pas dire ça pour quoi
non parce qu'il va s'énerver ou du
dissident tan ça parce que j'étais dans
mon lit dit par olivier tu peux aller
chercher une bière dans le frigo est ok
non non non dernier coup de fil c'était
c'était avec à l'amuser inventé un truc
parce qu'il boucle ou 1 c'est bien les
gonzesses à moi on peut c'est parce que
c'est incroyable j'étais dedans si d'en
bas avec mon téléphone portable à côté
toujours et je fais toujours des trucs
l'oreillette je suis retombé dans le
bain c'est abominable et je parle et
m'appellent quelqu'un c'est lui mais qui
semble aux minables
ah oui quand on se bat patty peut-être
taille puis je vais olivier qui attend
c'est qui au téléphone s'est énervé lui
voilà c'est normal quand on est une
fille comme vous qu'on y tiennent à
donner c'est vrai les choses d'en
découdre rouge du genre où tu vas non je
peux pas parce que j'ai les dents très
pour eux pour eux oui donc si je vois du
baron donc j'avais les dents pour eux
c'est aussi une buvette guerre mondiale
deviennent rouges non crise
voilà près de dix minutes mais lui et du
vin blanc
c'est ce que je fais seul c'était à
courchevel il ya deux semaines et une
vie d'enfer olivier tu allais faire les
soirées un peu mondaine et moi je prie
j'ai pris une bouteille de vin rouge
magnifique avec une assiette de fromage
comme ça et ça et la télévision
fantastique les dendrites tout seul
c'est vraiment moi je pense quand même
que michele valley
d'accord dernier coup de soleil il ya
très longtemps
tu mens plus le soleil je mets de
l'autobronzant parce que le soleil ça me
fait dit vous voyez là oui regardez là
où j'oublie de mettre le dos de l'écran
total
et là il ya quelques mois alors que là
et là y'a rien elle a donc elle a appris
le soleil
la gare découvert c'est gentil ça une
chanson ça c'est une chanson elle a
gardé ses le prochain album tu sors tu
veux le faire avec la face b au toit
majorettes majorettes et non la gouaille
est tombé à moi je dis pas tout fromage
tout ça a déjà un point commun ouais on
aime le fromage et le bain j'ai pas mal
dernier coup de blues au tout le temps
ah bon tout le temps j'arrive à dormir
le soir et donc je suis insomniaque et
donc ça n'est plus en vie sont figés
mais son seul os de sa développe le font
pas et nuit hallucinante
oui donc quand on est obligé de se lever
alors qu'on adore mes trois ans et voulu
dormir vie oui c'est dur matin streit
radio à ne pas dormir je sais ce qu'ils
tombent dans ma retraite et je n'arrive
pas je voulais pas prendre le somnifère
vous êtes comprends pas vous en prenez
prend mais le matin on n'est pas bien
non plus maya des trucs nouveaux
maintenant qui dure que trois heures
dont encore donc c'est bon ce qui
n'arrive pas à s'endormir
c'est pas pour ceux qui travaillent la
nuit donc je prends cela mais c'est vrai
que comme tout le monde j'ai c'est de ne
pas en prend tous les soirs mais je sens
qu'on s'en va arriver je me dis ce soir
je sens que ça devient après on focalise
voilà à vous avez eu la même chose non
mais je vous comprends tellement bien
ben déjà je suis en parfaite empathie
avec milan la dernière question
rituel alice evans dernier coup de rein
et à celle d'il ya sept ans est
heureusement écurie est là pour traduire
merci ça fait dix jours bamendjou silva
dernier coup de bluff la fête bouillon
dernier combat je suis à londres qui
vous y en avoir mais c'est vrai que
j'arrive que ce matin au
lalalalalalalalala avis erreur à la
cuisse dès son deuxième match de kevin
lima avec mendoze gérard depardieu dans
un cinéma près de chez vous